.
Michaël Roy.
- C'est terminé!
Eh bien, après 36 ans d'att
le Canada se qualifie pour
la deuxième Coupe du monde
de son histoire.
- Une équipe qui rassemble
tout le pays depuis plusieurs
semaines. Des joueurs
de soccer qui, déjà, inspirent
une nouvelle génération.
Prochaine étape : ce vendredi
1er avril, alors qu'aura lieu
le tirage au sort des groupes
phase finale de
la Coupe du monde de soccer.
Le Canada occupe actuellement
le 33e rang du classement
de la FIFA, un sommet dans
son histoire.
Et qui sait ce que cette jeune
équipe, sans complexes,
pourra accomplir si le tirage
lui est favorable.
- Et le but!
- En 1986, lors de la dernière
et seule participation
canadienne à la grande messe
du soccer, le Canada avait subi
trois défaites en trois matc
et n'avait pas marqué un seul
but contre la France, la Hongrie
et l'Union soviétique.
Cette fois, par contre,
les Canadiens n'arrivent plus
en néophytes. La formation
fait parler d'elle sur la scène
internationale. Le
compte dans ses rangs
des vedettes internationales
comme Alfonso Davies et
Jonathan David.
Et ses récentes victoires
en phase qualificative contre
les États-Unis et le Mexique
ont envoyé le message
qu'ils ne seront pas au Qatar
en figurants, comme c'était
le cas au Mexique il y a 36 ans.
Les yeux du monde entier
se tourneront dava
prochainement vers le pays hôte,
où le contexte sociopolitique
n'a rien de reluisant.
Après les accusations de
corruption lors de l'obtention
du tournoi, le pays s'est
transformé en véritable
chantier de construction.
tiers où la main-
d'oeuvre est composée à 90 %
de travailleurs étrangers.
Et c'est le sort de ces derniers
qui demeure sous la loupe
internationale, alors que
pleuvent les accusations de
maltraitance et d'esclavagisme.
Plusieurs appellentau boycottag.
Les premiers matchs
auront lieu à la fin du mois
de novembre prochain.
Ici Michaël Roy,